pensioners living in big family houses
are to be given incentives to downsize
part of the government's new housing
strategy being unveiled this week in a
big shake-up of housing policy the prime
minister says she'll put generation rent
at the heart of her plans and increase
the number of affordable rental homes
what with me now is Natalie elphick from
the housing and finance Institute who
fed into the government's proposal at
justice one on downsizing is that really
going to make much difference in the end
well Adam we do hear that some
pensioners do find that they are capital
rich that penny poor so having to find
those stamp duty costs up front does
stop them moving to another home so I
think for those pensioners this could be
a welcome help but that's by no means
going to solve the housing challenges or
build those family homes that young
people in particular one per having
there's also a problem for elderly
people who want to downsize which is a
bridging loans that exist anymore so
it's very difficult for them to get the
new property for them to moving I think
there are a range of measures that we
can expect to see to help older people
move move their homes but the key really
is unlocking that housing supply and to
the generation rent to help that
generation rent to become generation by
people still want to buy their own home
like their parents and indeed their
grandparents I thought the government
was changing his attitude towards that
there's now going to focus on the rental
area not so much sure talk about the
homely democracy it doesn't look comes
from the comments over the weekend as if
the government has abandoned be home
owning democracy and this is such an
important issue for particularly the
younger generation and many people do
get very angry that they can't have the
same affordable housing options of
ownership for their parents and
grandparents and so it is going to
continue to be an important part of
participation you know one of the
problems actually created by the whole
idea of encouraging home ownership by 07
off council houses by selling off
Housing Association properties that is
actually taking cheap rental property
off the market additional price I think
what we're seeing is what that is
because we're saying that there is there
has been a
huge increase in property ownership in
other generation of decreasing in social
housing being built both by housing
associations and by council well if we
look at 2015-16 the amount of property
that actually is coming forward has you
know has been very strong so again I
think when we look over the last 20 or
30 years there's been some really good
years for affordable housing delivery
but we need to do more across all types
of housing and it would be really
welcome when housing white paper comes
forward if it is bringing forward real
commitments to those million new homes
the most important thing for all types
of homeowners and all types of renters
is to get the high quality additional
housing that our country is needed I
mean the problem is that's a decade's
successive governments of different
colors have set out these bold hi all
speaking building targets and it never
happens they never hit their target so
how is that going to be changed well
just a few days ago the National Audit
Office issued a paper which did confirm
that the government had exceeded its own
housing net supply target of 174,000 hey
190,000 homes in the last year and it
was on track to build those million
homes I think when the white paper comes
out we're looking for a confirmation
that the million homes is still this
government's target and for an
understanding of what the balance of
those million homes will be will it be
more rented housing which is certainly
what we've heard over the last 24 hours
or whether also be options different
ways perhaps to ransom by perhaps shared
ownership different routes donor ship
for those who also want to get on the
housing ladder and in terms of building
are we building the right sort of houses
at the moment or homes and because other
than the apartment something well those
there is a lot of building and that had
diff accelerated over recent years so
now when we look at the position as our
country came out of the credit crunch I
mean housing absolutely I just collapsed
I mean less than 90 thousand homes built
after the credit crunch that's now up to
140,000 round that number of new
buildings on the kindy 400 it's 190 on
that housing supply which is a very very
big achievement that's conversions
that's all the types of things that
bring forward for housing go to
things are quite different things and
their importance in looking at the
challenge that the government has set
down as the million homes that's house
building and there's total housing
supply so all those conversions changes
of use better use of property to make
sure we're not just building but we're
using property as well as we can to me
helping me as far as first-time buyers
are concerned this government the trees
and may government is change its
approach from the David Cameron George
Osborne one is though right well I think
we've got to see what the detail is in
the housing white paper I mean certainly
the housing and Planning Minister has
indicated a return to the affordable
rent and affordable home buying approach
which has been the long tradition in
this country so i think that was and he
said i think he called it as change of
tone and i think we've seen that change
of tune he was also very clear that he
was addressing a very specific challenge
for renters at the moment and I think
it's one we will recognize if you're a
renter at the moment it doesn't feel
that you get particularly a fair deal
and I think what the government's done
and what we're expecting them to do in
the white paper is to say for renters
they are housing consumers and we need
to make sure that they get a fair deal
for being housing consumers as renters
thank you very much thank you very much